okay let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another
episode of your favorite podcast
[Music]
is
[Music]
all right that's enough
[Music]
all right anyways we did a quick intro
uh this week whatever i mean you guys
know the intro
it is what it is it is what it is uh
welcome back to riffing with griffin
another week another just me you know
uh was gonna have rachel on but she like
went out with her friends
you know it's weird because i don't know
how i feel about it because at first i'm
the one that was always encouraging her
i said you know you gotta get go out
with your friends
you know what i mean like i said you
need some friends you need you know
because
rachel was like not keeping up with her
friends like she wouldn't even like
call him i always have to ask her hey
how are your friends how's so-and-so
how's what you call it you know
and then she finally started hanging out
with her friends again like you know one
of them
you know i was like oh i'm going out
with uh
emily and whatever then this one and so
now she's like going out all the time
with her friends and i think you know
it's good
but then i found myself being like a
little jealous which i wasn't before
i'm just not a jealous type but then
like when you spend so much time with
someone for like so long like you know
so it's been like almost eight months of
quarantine
and i was spending like just a lot of
time
with her or i knew where she was like it
was like she's going to work
and then she's coming back and she's
with me and then like you know and i
wasn't doing anything but i'm at home
and i'm on twitch like five hours a day
or whatever it is i'm doing so i it
wasn't even like i was
uh doing anything and then now i started
doing a couple of shows and now she's
going out with her friends and i'm just
kind of like oh it's like a different
feeling you know
and of course she loves it i mean i
think you're i think women
i mean just women i just think like your
partner likes when you're
a little jealous i think a little
jealousy is okay
uh but not when it becomes like
debilitating but like just to have a
healthy like oh
oh you wouldn't you know it's like when
one of your friends does something well
this happens a lot in the entertainment
business like especially comedy
you know i'm coming up with a lot of
dudes you know i i just doing open mics
and or even just like
even on a bigger scale let's say so
there's like a community at the comedy
store and there's
all these guys were paid regulars we're
at the heart of the
lineup every every week and you know on
the weekends
you know and then you're just waiting to
hear about you know somebody gets a
sitcom
somebody gets a show and you know you're
a little bit like damn
like you don't feel bad for people like
i feel happy for people
and i feel envious in a way like i wish
i was doing that but at the same time
i used that to push me there's a there's
like a scale where it gets
too far then you're like it turns into
like negativity but you know there's a
little bit of that
it's even when people like start
podcasts like some people's podcasts
really blow up
and then sometimes other people's
podcast it just doesn't blow up you know
or has a small rise or like whatever it
is
you know i think it's okay to have a
healthy little i think a
a healthy amount of jealousy is uh
okay you know you guys ever go to the
urban dictionary i just [ __ ] keep coming
on you ever go to the urban dictionary
so much to the urban dictionary you know
cause like there was a word that people
keep saying all the time i always see it
in the comments too
you know they're like uh oh such a
so-and-so is a simp
s-i-m-p and i don't know what the hell
that meant at first i thought it was
like
somebody being like overly sensitive
like sympathetic
you know what i mean like oh that
person's being too sensitive
but actually according to urban
dictionary means someone who does
way too much for a person they like
i don't know with this i don't know how
i feel about that
you people that are listening and
watching right now is that what you
thought a simp was
someone who does way too much for
someone they like
and then they um and then they have like
a uh on the urban dictionary they have a
thing goes brian shoe the simp
i bought her a car and a whole ass house
and we're not even dating
[Laughter]
well i mean that just sounds crazy
or you just so rich it don't matter to
you but like damn
i i didn't i was in mine you ever use
a urban dictionary word the wrong way
like
in your mind you thought it was
something else yeah
so that's what i said i thought it was
like somebody just being too sympathetic
or too sensitive but this is some under
way too much
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about that i think sometimes you
they people come up with these words and
terms and it causes a dead end and
there's nowhere to go
you know and i think that's just a weak
way out of not dealing with
whatever the circumstances are i'll give
you a perfect example it's mansplaining
mansplaining is that is just a
complete stop mansplaining and uh
another one that but i totally get like
this one is not necessarily what i'm
saying but like gas lighting
when people say that oh you're
gaslighting me that's a little different
because
i believe that does happen when people
act like oh i don't know what you were
talking what
were you talking about i didn't know
that you know that's
you know but it's like but when you use
gas lighting with mansplaining
it's like like i can't stand
mansplaining is like
when people say that it's just there's
nowhere to go it's a dead end
you're talking to somebody a female or a
woman or whatever
i even get slack for that don't call
women females i don't understand what
someone's got to explain to me in the
comments why female is now
now bad you know it's like women
it's like uh it's like what you call
black people for the last hundred years
you got to keep changing it it's like
colored
negro black african-american
you know all these different terms that
each generation we go okay now this is
okay i think
it's gonna be the same thing with women
right now so now female is bad i i guess
i don't know but anyway
when people say you mansplain it's like
so like if you're a guy like myself i
talk a lot i make jokes
i formulate thoughts in my head and i
present them and i present them in this
way
so you know sometimes i think like this
like how i'm doing in a podcast like
right now i have to explain to you like
what i'm thinking about and why i'm
talking about it so someone could watch
it to be like
oh he's mansplaining uh what it's like
yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] you you know what i mean yeah
i'm i'm i'm explaining myself
i'm i'm organizing a thought i'm
explaining how i feel about it
and then you look at me and go oh you're
mansplaining
okay so how do you want me to talk look
i get it if somebody's being
condescending
that's the term you use hey don't talk
to me in a condescending manner
but to just say if a dude is talking to
you in a condescending manner and you
call that
mansplaining and then someone's not
talking to you in a condescending manner
but they're just explaining like hey
listen this is what i'm trying to say
right now and you go oh you're
mansplaining like then what do we do
how do we talk please explain to me how
i'm supposed to talk to you
uh especially if we're in an argument
too
like if we're having an argument or
we're having a disagreement or and
you're making your point and i'm making
my point
and my point is mansplaining when i'm
making my point and
what's your thing how do we uh
i don't know it's just so that just
seems like that's just one of those
terms
so i thought that simple was one of
these terms too i guess i don't know
i was looking at an urban dictionary and
there's like a lot of weird words in
here
um that that
you just go what it what is this and
apparently they come up with some all
the time
so like the october trends on for
urban dictionary watermelon sugar i
don't know what the hell that is
watermelon sugar it's sugar
from a watermelon what did you expect it
says
uh so it means like what the hell are
you talking about but they have the f
word here what the
what the f are you talking about try not
to cuss as much as i normally do because
apparently youtube's cracking down on
that even though i already did in this
episode right so
i'm trying to catch myself but i'm not
always going to but that's what
watermelon sugar
i don't want to get that it says oh [ __ ]
i should change the definition then it's
too late you posted it someone is
already reading it
that's watermelon sugar okay so i don't
i don't get that one
somebody's got to somebody's gonna have
to explain to my old ass what that means
here's another one the new these are the
october trending
uh urban dictionary ghetto spread
it's like debit spread but you you buy
the
option first and when your price goes up
in the case of a call or down in the
case
of a put you sell i don't get it
the way even though you maxed your
profits you eliminate the risk
ghetto spread oh so i guess you
spreading out your
it's like i i don't get this
i i i don't get
i don't get the urban dictionary like
who
decides this stuff so they had this
other one it's called
oh so this is like october 3rd word of
the day
thoughts and prayers i could care less
but one must keep up appearances right
yeah i guess when people say that
you know that's like pressure from the
internet you know like something bad
happens and then you
you feel yourself having to say
something especially in the last like
throughout this quarantine that's been
the whole thing too with all the stuff
that has happened like george floyd
that's how people are about black lives
matter too i think
they say thoughts and prayers for black
lives matter and it just means in an
urban dictionary that you could really
care less
but you got to keep up appearances okay
see that one i understand
that that one that one uh sort of makes
sense to me
um i don't i don't even understand
somebody sorority squat
what is a sorority squat
typically performed by sorority sisters
immediately prior to a picture
where one or more participants slightly
bend their knees and okay so it's just
girls taking pictures
i don't know that's weird so anyway
that's my weird urban dictionary rant
whatever the hell that means so rachel
and i went on a double date
again the other day with uh two of our
friends that we went on a double date
with the other time
miles and amanda but we went to their
place
and i really felt like an adult because
we were playing
a card game i forgot the name of the
game but it was like
it was it had all these intricate rules
but once you got into the hang of it it
was like so you had like
number it had like number values
on them like you know and then you're
you have to have four cards
and then like you know you have to like
put your cards down in twos
and then you like you you turn them like
this each time you put a stack
and if somebody has the same card as you
they could steal your
top stack unless you have a wild card or
the same card you can like counter them
and then you put it in that stack but
then someone else could still take it
so we were playing this card game and i
just felt like man i feel like one of
those like
just having a game night like how many
people have game
you do game nights you know so it was
great you know and
and then uh the dude miles he like he
made some great steak uh
he has we had steak fajitas you know so
he like had his little mask on and he
went out to
his uh courtyard of his building and you
know cooked
and then you know brought the steaks up
and i was like oh this was great and i
just really felt like oh look at me i'm
doing like adult stuff
i'm just like i've been such a loner my
whole life
you know i've just dealt with life is
like even if i have people
in my life i always felt like well i'm
still going to do things by myself
you know so it's weird to like you know
now that i i have this woman in my life
and now she's just like such a such a
us now it's not like me so i don't think
about like oh i have to do something i'm
always thinking about like okay
what are we gonna do or like what's the
plan for us and you know so going out
with like
friends and stuff like that it was
really it was really cool
you know it was really cool you know
it's just it just reminds me of like i
just want the world to get back to
normal
you know it's a tough thing people keep
talking about the coronavirus in terms
of like hey
we got to just keep doing the social
distancing and all this
you know like i was on this zoom call
with my uh girl's family
and you know one of her uncles you know
he's
really big on like you know the
chronovirus is out of control you know
it's good it's spreading you know but
then you like so you tell me to go to a
john hopkins website about the
chronovirus so i was like okay because i
asked him like how do you get
information about this because
everybody that has strong feelings about
their chronovirus
they're talking about it is talking
about it as if they
have the particular source that has the
correct information
and i maintain that i don't think anyone
has
the real information it's so
much mistrust in the media right now
from
us the consumer from the people that
there's so much mistrust that
how can i know that this place is
the place that has the real information
like where are they getting it from
if the cdc if we can't trust the cdc's
website
the the they're the for disease control
they're the center for disease control
you know this is the place that is
supposed to be the end-all be-all when
it comes to like when if there's
diseases and viruses and stuff if we
can't trust them
what is to what are what's to become of
us
so you know so i go to this john hopkins
you know
website to look at like because people
keep talking right now like it's spiking
again
you know that's spiking so like you go
to like
you know florida like florida's the big
one you know
let i'm gonna go to it now and i'll
probably put up um
i'll probably put up this graph
you know so i'm gonna go to it right now
as i'm talking to you guys on my phone
so like john hopkins has it as the
global confirmed
you know coronavirus cases is 42
million 926 000
confirmed global confirmed cases then
one
1 million deaths
and in the u.s alone it's 8 million
635 752
and the us deaths are 225
000. i mean no one should die
but that number seems right in line
considering that we're on month
or on the eighth month of the
coronavirus
seven they say march april may june july
august september
october yeah we're in the eighth month
so you're talking about
uh let's see five more months
five more months it'll be a year uh
and what's like the total of the number
of people that die from like
the flu and flu related illnesses in a
in a calendar year
is it close to that number or is it
around that number i mean i'm not saying
it's the same but
like obviously what i'm saying is is 225
000
is that the number that we go we need to
decimate
our economy and put people out of
business forever
is that the number because apparently
that's the number but anyways my point
is
you know you go to this website you know
according to him
and you know you're you start tracking
because you could
you know they have this tracking on
these websites where you go alright so
you can go by state you know
so you go to john hopkins you go to
tracking you know they have like the
critical data
right and so let's say you go um
all right so here we go so for instance
if i go to all right i'm gonna go to
like california
all right we've been closed you know so
they have their little
they have their little the the thing the
spikes they show the spikes you know
restriction close so when we closed we
closed because we were at a high spike
and now
we're back down now it's october and
despite it's
higher than it was say when we first
started but it's not as high as it was
when it first
opened okay so now it's come down
you know and so
yeah i wish they would show us like the
the actual numbers
you know like the case you know
so i could like see the numbers but i
mean as you look at this you know you go
new deaths
yeah so you can like look at this this
chart right so you guys got to go to
this website and you look at the chart
um but then like you go to florida you
know so i'm looking at this and i go to
florida who's been pretty much
open you know most of the time
and i look at their chart and it looks
exactly the same as california
like it looks like the the when it
spiked it spiked when
you know when it first opened and now
they're saying you know i'm looking at
this and i go well i don't get it
i don't i don't see
if the charts are exactly the same in
two places that
that have treated it completely
different
what are we doing does that make sense
am i making sense to you guys maybe
people are watching you're being like
griffin you're being stupid
let me try to explain it again what i'm
saying is if you have a place that has
multiple millions of people because
florida has a huge population
california has a huge population
so you look at those graphs of like the
chronovirus charts and it shows that
there was this huge spike
when you know stuff started to open up
you know
and then you see the chart and it seems
to be what i'm saying is
florida who has pretty much been open
they've been more open than we have and
their chart looks very
similar to our chart so therefore
why are why aren't we open is what i'm
saying if the chart is going to look
exactly the same why aren't we open
but i guess the other side of it i'm
just using my you know common sense
you know i'm not a scientist or anything
like that so i'm just talking out my ass
right now but we're just talking about
it cause i'm sure you guys do the same
thing
i'm sure you're like you know you go
cause like a lot of people send put
comments on my podcast and they're just
like
oh you know don't be stupid but i'm like
where are you getting your information
from
like you show me where you're getting
your information from so
you know i got it from somebody who's
very liberal who is
super concerned about the coronavirus
you know who thinks that you know
what the states are doing is bad and
this is supposed to show it
but i go to this website and i don't see
it
i don't see if i look at florida's
numbers because that's the one because
that's the one everybody's always
talking about everybody's always talking
about florida florida florida florida
they're terrible they're terrible
but you look and you go well do they
have any more cases
than than we do it doesn't look like it
or that what i'm saying is the chart
seems to be doing the exact same thing
it seems to be
that this is like a national thing like
like
all right what am i trying to say so
like to me it would seem that
i would want to see like let's say when
it first started
and then because we weren't being safe
then it started to go like this right
all right so at a place let's say that
they were trying to be
safe it shows like in
connecticut or wherever they show they
they close things down early
so they broke their curve went down all
right so so obviously then
if if you had closed earlier maybe we
could have defeated this
earlier okay so the places that didn't
do that that have larger populations
that it's you know it's obviously much
harder to get people to like not
go out and do even just basic everyday
everyday stuff all right so then that
kind of place you look at california
california
if you look at any charter california it
started to go up then there was this
huge
uh uptick and then it came back down
and now it it's going
up again but not like the huge but it's
higher than it was when it started right
so that chart looks like this it goes up
and then it goes across
i'll show it right there all right my
point is the california one
and the florida one they look very
similar
but florida has been open so for me i
put that together and i go then why
isn't california open
like it really ticks me off to hear how
as a
i'm just speaking selfishly as a
comedian as someone whose business has
completely shut down it's just been
decimated by it okay
um they're talking about open up theme
parks
that the theme park people what
what so mickey mouse
so disneyland can open up but i can't go
do comedy in the comedy store parking
lot
really to explain that to me i
cuz i don't understand it so i so
people are outside in lines how's that
gonna work
how many people are gonna allow into the
place like are they gonna be in the
rides like
i just don't get how that is possible so
the
my only explanation is it's about money
like that
what else could it possibly be other
than
they're losing so much money it's such a
huge corporation that they're putting
pressure on the government so they're
like okay let's open up theme parks
but the little comedy clubs and like you
can't do comedy at like
on rooftop bars you can't do comedy and
like
there's so many different little places
like the improv in hollywood they have
this great outdoor
patio in the front of the comedy club
where they you know they can sell drinks
and
you know it's like an open area so we
can't do shows right there
that's i i don't understand it don't
tell me you care about health and safety
and you're gonna open up disneyland okay
don't
because that don't make no sense to me
all right so but anyways
i would really like to know where people
are getting you know their
covet information you know show it to me
like if you have some website you go oh
this is the website
this is the website that i trust you
know i trust this website
80 or 100 or 50 show me
because i'm looking at this stuff
that uh my my
fiance's uncle was like adamantly about
like oh
things are not looking well and i look
at this and i go well
explain it to me because i don't
understand it so i don't know
so they had the um this new the new
presidential debate and man these two
guys are clown faces
man i just it was i wish they would have
just arm wrestled it would it would have
been
better like i didn't get a sense other
than like it was just a lot of
mudslinging
i started to think back is it always
like that are debates always like that
is there no moment where they're
discussing like
here's my plan and this is why i think
my plan will work
these two guys was just like this one
took money
that one doesn't pay his taxes this one
doesn't do that
you know you know then and then they're
they're making these accusations
just it seems like you could just say
whatever you want willy nilly
like like trump is going like you took
money from russia
he just said it i wish he would have
like had some facts you know
he could have came there with facts he's
the president you know you got the
fbi the cia the nsa you got all these
things at your disposal you have all the
records and files you're the freaking
president of the united states
he could have came out and been like
well according to uh
this investigation done by my whatever
you you took money on this date
and then have biden explain it so you
say you didn't take money but this guy's
saying that you did
but it wasn't like that it was just kind
of like you did this
and the other one's like you did that
and i just thought to myself man
like what what are you two clown faces
doing and i thought they both made good
points look
i'm not a trump guy per se you know i'm
but i'm not like some crazy liberal
either
but one of the points i thought trump
made that i thought was a win for him
when he was talking about minimum wage
man
you know it's like every state's
different and he's a hundred percent
correct man
like i live in california the cost of
living in california is astronomical
the taxes are too high and the cost of
living so 15
an hour in california is poverty
but it ain't poverty in alabama so
should it be a national uh you know
national uh minimum wage
no i thought the guy made a decent point
with that
and then you know but then i thought it
was like man i wish they would discuss
it like that but they just
it seems that in politics politicians
can't have
a balanced open discussion going back
and forth
and then the the things i like joe biden
said i think he said this a few times
and i really
totally agree with this sentiment is
i'm not just a democratic president i'm
your president i'm
everybody's president you know if he
were to win
even the people that don't like me i'm
your president too
that is something that trump does not he
doesn't
he doesn't come across like that's how
he cares i
he really does come across like all he
cares about is his base
like let me make sure i got this base
happy and then we'll see about everyone
else
but i really wish that there was more of
that on both sides
you know the same like hey listen
because that's the
the democratic system i mean to me it's
supposed to be
you have two good candidates that both
parties
go we like our guy and the other party's
like well we like our guy
they go through this election process
and then whoever wins the other side's
got to go all right you got us this time
all right now let's support this guy and
move forward
but that's not what's happening you know
it's just
the one side doesn't win they just so
fundamentally
polar opposite of each other that they
can't find a way to work together for
the greater good
there seems to be no greater good
conversation so
i don't know and then now the election's
coming up but it seems like there's like
record turnout in voting so i do
encourage people to do that keep voting
man go out and vote
make make yourself known make your you
know
this is great i think the more people
that vote the more people that are
involved in the election the better it
is
i mean if we're so inspired because you
absolutely hate trump now you're
starting to go oh i need to come out and
vote well good for you
or if you're people that are like man
this country is running great right now
i need to go out and make sure my guy
stays in you go out and vote too
because we've just been too complacent
as a nation when it comes to like voting
so
hopefully this will uh you know bring a
a real good positive change in the in
the voting process but who knows man
it's like there are there's some people
that feel like if one side wins it's
going to be terrible
for everyone and there's going to be
like unrest and if the other side wins
same kind of thing i mean i
i just don't know i hope that we can
rise above all of this
disdain that people have for each other
and
um rise above it and just make this
happen like you know like we could just
get
back on track but i just don't feel
confident that either
is going to be able to keep us on the
straight and narrow
the way they are going at each other and
all these things that you hear about you
know behind the scenes but
anyways i ain't trying to this is
already too long with politics as it is
so let's get to the fun stuff so i
rachel just came home so even though i
tell her i'm
doing my podcast she still has to open
the door
it's like no matter what you're doing
they're gonna
they're just gonna come in and like do
their thing you know what i mean
it is what it is anyways
so what's going on else in my world
right now i
so i've big brother's heating up
for you big brother people um i'm not
gonna go into like
big heavy big brother talk right now
because it's about to be done
so they got tyler out they got christmas
out so now it's just
cody enzo and nicole those are the three
that are left
and you hear the jury how they're
talking about it and they all think that
somebody should make a big move that's
who they're gonna like vote for
you know so i just hope that a big you
know i hope somebody makes a big move
but at this point right now
i just i don't know i don't know it's
like
i just want to see somebody do something
that makes everybody go
oh i can't believe she voted that guy
out but it's about to happen now
because here's the thing enzo keeps
talking about
he wants cody like enzo's already messed
up in my opinion
he can't win unless he kicks cody out
like that'll be his like if it comes
down to the three he's got to take
nicole
he's got like look because he's just
gonna come across that he rode cody's
coattails all the way to the end
cody's won numerous competitions he's
never been on the block
he's gonna win if he's sitting in the
final two period there's just no way
he can't win unless he if he's because
he he played a great social game
that's that now if nicole
if she somehow ends up sitting next to
enzo
and she's she's the reason cody gets
kicked out how can enzo beat her
she is now already won
and now she's all-star season she's made
it to the she
at that point she would have made it to
the final two she's the one
she should win over enzo like what has
he
even done he can't win any competitions
like i think the guy made a huge mistake
and cody said something great because he
said
the last time he won he came in second
place because he he was loyal
the whole he was loyal to the person to
the end
and it cost him he lost like five to two
yeah because that loyalty
that ain't gonna win you to five hundred
thousand dollars because the people
there are just
they're just the people that lost they
lost out on five hundred thousand
dollars
so they want to see why they lost out of
500 000 they want to see like you know
who what did you do to make to uh you
know to get yourself to that final stage
they want to know that you
played a solid game not like just a
coattail game so
we'll see i think that but like i said
if enzo decides
he has to say he wins ahead of house so
he has the choice to kick cody out
he should make that choice for his game
because that'll be
great for the jury to be like hey man i
rolled all the way
and i kicked him out because that's what
i needed to do to win
and you know i think he'll get he'll get
people's votes but
i don't know to me it's cody's game to
lose
and if nicole can kick cody out she'll
be a first two-time winner
all right it's exciting you got you guys
okay i'm a big big big brother guy
something i don't even know what
happened tonight like it came on as i'm
recording this right now
but i didn't watch yet so we'll be i'll
talk about it next week now
you know here's a new show that i've
been watching this is the first time
i've ever
ever wait i gotta get my phone too
because
i gotta make sure i get the the people's
name right you know
but this is the first well my chair just
went down
uh so this is the first time i've ever
watched the bachelor or bachelorette
it's the first time i've ever watched
the show so
they got this chick on the show her
name's claire and she's the oldest
bachelorette ever
she's 30 well i mean not to say that
this is old but
she's 39. all right let me ask y'all
something
and i know i can't hear the answers but
are we going to be 100 on riffing with
griffin
because you know me i'm i keep [ __ ] 100.
i'm trying to let's be real let's be
like
this ain't trying to be mean this isn't
like for any hot take
this just is what it is
she's too old for the bachelor
for this group of bachelors by the way
it just i it makes me uncomfortable when
i watch it
like to me she needs to have
like more distinguished guys
uh more strong personality men
uh you know maybe a dude who's all the
way up to 50
55 who's in you know he's a businessman
he's like hey you know i
i just like some of these guys they're
just boys
to her they're like this 30 year old
is talking about trying to marry her
they have nothing in common some of them
it's just so
bizarre some of the guys i go yes
this looks like a match like it looks
like okay this guy has the wherewithal
it's really a testament to her by the
way
it has nothing to do with uh um
her like like because i don't mean that
like
she's too old like physically old
i'm saying the match isn't good for some
of these guys
like some of the guys they're just like
just these 30 year old dudes
you know they're all these like fratty
type
guys or these like athletic dudes
ex-football players and all this kind of
stuff in there
and i'm like what are you doing and it
just seems ridiculous like
how they have it set up so you have this
woman who like
so insecure she just exudes insecurities
she's you know she's always talking
about how men have never treated me like
this and so you just kind of watch and
you're like well i mean
are you are you ready for this
experience
are you are you ready for all these
types of people to come to
to to be in your life i just i don't
think so sometimes
just from watching the show you know and
then she did this crazy thing where
she meets one of the guys this guy dale
right he's like an ex football player a
light skinned black dude
who is shaped handsome dude and she like
meets him and she's like i think i just
met my husband
so now for the first two episodes all
she doing is talking about him
like the whole thing is about him and i
go you're now
not even open to all of these
relationships that
are in front of you you you're doing the
thing that you've always done
going off feeling oh the feel like what
feeling you don't even notice dude you
know
nothing about him you know what i mean
like you just met the guy
and you know and even if there's like
rumors that they had talked before
but even still like what do you know
about this guy that you're just gonna
discount
this process of getting to know these
other people like it's so
crazy and then there's always going to
be a double standard let's just be real
about this
there is a double standard when it comes
to men and women we don't have the same
standard you know
it's positive and negative on both sides
for instance
she has a dodgeball game with the guys
and she makes them play
strip dodgeball so these guys are out
they have to blur the whole thing
because
dick and balls is obviously just hanging
out
[ __ ] like just just ass the dudes
are
all these hunky n-shaped dudes are just
like you know
naked do you think even for a
second and i never watched a show so i
don't even know if this even this could
have happened for all i know
but i doubt that if you had the bachelor
and he was playing strip anything with
the bachelorettes
making them compete and then get naked
for him
i mean would that be a thing so
just i'm looking at this and it just was
it the whole thing just made me go like
what
what are we doing man like what what is
this show about
so i don't know i just i just feel like
i just feel like this season is going to
be a disaster and it's just
and we're and we're setting up for it
like it's just there's just
no way that this could possibly work
you know i don't even know how many
bachelor bachelorettes marriages have
actually lasted
because it seems to me that big brother
marriages
are stronger and more real than these
like
things that are supposed to be for
marriage like i would love to know the
numbers of how many bachelor
bachelorettes in the last 17 years
however
how many years they've been doing the
show how many of these marriages on the
show are actually
are they still together or are they
successful because i know a lot of big
breathing marriages
are are going great it's because it
wasn't about that they met on the show
and then that shared experience
they left the show continued they
started to date and then they realized
oh wow and they fell in love and they
got married and they have kids
i mean there's a lot of big brother
marriages but the bachelor bachelorette
i don't know i mean the double like
getting back to the double standard in
society too is like
there is a double standard so you know
if if the dude was
39 you know and the women on the show
were like
30 would that be okay i guess that would
be okay but i don't know
you know like if these women were like
in their early 20 like late 20s
say late 20s 30s and then women's 39
and the guy was 39 like how would that
would we would we be more accepting of
it
probably i mean look at even my own
situation is is similar to that i'm i'm
older than
rachel um but you know it's just this
just comes across like
she's being very like mom to these guys
it doesn't come across
like there are equals in these
situations
other than the ones that she and then
she's kissing everybody but i guess that
happens on the bachelor too
you know so again that's just that weird
double standard that we have about like
women aren't allowed to like do the same
things that men do but like this is like
episode one
she already kissing like episode one and
two she gonna kiss like six people i
think
but at the same time still talking about
this one guy dale like she is
harping on this guy and i just go you
already let him know
he's the one so like it's like
i just don't i just don't get it like
this show it's a train wreck
it's a train wreck ready to happen and
you just you really
i've never watched a bachelor
bachelorette ever before
but i'm telling you right now you should
watch it just to see how uncomfortable
it's gonna make you feel
when you watch her trying to maneuver
through
[Music]
you know this experience of like for the
first time
how she even says it herself i've never
had these many
kind of different personalities and guys
and i'm the center of attention and
she's still
like there was this oh this is great it
was this moment where all right so she
has like a group of them there
and you know they're all they're all
sitting there
and they make a toast you know and then
there's like this
awkward silence right no one says
anything
you know and then one guy she goes okay
and then one guy finally goes hey let's
okay i want to spend time with you and
takes her off
now she's off talking with this guy and
she's just thinking and thinking she
goes
listen i'm you know this is really
bugging me i have to go back and talk to
everyone
so she goes back she leaves this guy
that finally one of them had the balls
to be like yo
let me go take you on a date you know a
date whatever like
whatever they do on the show and goes
back over and it's like
hey um you know let me
she tells the guys she goes you know do
you guys want to spend time with each
other
or do you want to spend time with me
like you guys just want to bro out cause
i could just go home
but i really felt like she just wanted
the guy
then dale steps up and takes her i
really felt like she was like
one she should have just came back and
said dale how come you didn't step up
and say something like it just
really was like such a like the whole
show is awkward as f
it's awkward
and i just can't wait to see and then
they keep showing like these previews of
like what's going to happen in the
season
and it seems like the whole thing blows
up and the guy says like
in my 17 years of big brother this has
been
i mean of the bachelor that's this has
never happened this has never happened
before so
and i'm like so interested but they got
me hooked man they got me
hooked so i do suggest you guys uh take
a look that see this chick
and she's beautiful you know she's 39
but you know she's beautiful
but it's like listen the part thing that
gets me to is like
these guys that are going for her
because of how society is it seems to me
like it's really like a showcase
for them because if you're on this show
and you're like
you know all these guys are like in
shape and like
you know ex-football player this guy's a
marketing guy this guy
they all have some kind of like thing
there's millions of women at home who
are watching the bachelorette going like
i'll date him you know i'm sure
i'm sure these dudes are getting just
hit up in their dms right now
being on the show just like hey if you
don't want to get with her you know get
with me i'm 25
and blah blah you know what i mean like
it just seems like there are better
matches out there
i just don't think that they picked
the right guys for her
it doesn't seem like good matches
and it's only going to make her
look bad like it's only it's not going
to be good for her that's just my
opinion of it but you guys might have a
different opinion so please
hit me up in in comments if you're a
bachelor bachelor follower but
you definitely should watch the show but
anyways guys um
next week rachel will be back and make
sure you watch uh
this wednesday i was gonna have real
world advice from a for a grown-ass man
now but i started to think you know what
maybe i should separate that so i'm
gonna see how that goes
so real world advice from a grown s man
it's coming to you on wednesday
and i'm gonna start doing that on
wednesdays and gonna have little
um now i'm gonna start to have little
videos and stuff
with rachel and i and i'm gonna put that
on the patreon and the youtube members
members only access so we're working on
that stuff now so
keep a lookout for that and you just
check out my patreon
all that stuff's in the links in the
bios and all that kind of stuff
short episode this week i really
appreciate you guys watching i'm going
to bring you content every single week
i do have some guests in the works we'll
see oh and uh some good news is that i
don't know if you guys saw
the people that follow me regularly and
know the whole world especially you
tiger belly people that follow me
you know i went on stevie weeby steve
lee's podcast
and we straightened everything out and
him and are real good again
not that we weren't good but it's just
like a big huge misunderstanding and so
you know him and i gonna start gaming
soon and you know
he's gonna come on my podcast and i went
on his for the fifth time and it was a
really fun episode it was really so make
sure you check out
that episode stevie movie the stevie
weeby show
on this on youtube and all the the
podcasting
stuff you know you guys can see that
stuff there but anyways uh once again
thanks for watching and again i also
game every single day
on twitch that's eric griffin gaming so
check that out
please subscribe share and keep watching
and keep interacting with me and keep
looking out for real world advice from
grownups man
i think i want to make an email for it
so like people can
send it to send me stuff i usually do it
on instagram so i can keep it tight
i look at it i grab the ones i want and
then it just disappears so i don't feel
like i've
so if i missed people it's just gone
into the ether as opposed to like having
it build up and build up and having to
keep looking back and back so
i wish i could get to everyone i try to
answer as much of them as i can on my uh
on my instagram but you know it is what
it is
i'm just trying to get some friendly
advice and sometimes it helps
people even if it's not your question so
make sure you look out for that on
wednesday
and you know like i say i'm gonna try to
put out some more content and i really
appreciate you guys watching ripple with
griffin
and i'll see you next week